sandra histoire de fou sept mois de
relation virtuelle avec un jeune homme
alors on va voir au début d'épisode soir
vous êtes très heureuse mais problème
vous allez vite déchanté cas vous
sentiez que quelque chose se tramait
avec guy avec qui vous aviez une
relation virtuelle depuis sept mois tout
ne se passe pas comme prévu on va revoir
les images que vous allez nous dire
qui fait un peu monter mon complément en
fait c'est mon binôme c'est mon crush
c'est mon grand frère est et ouest et
c'est mon tour je n'ai jamais ressenti
ça
[Musique]
quand tu vois
j'avais étonné de me voir c'est normal
on se connaît pas colombie
c'est peut-être on s'est trompé il ya
erreur et c'est pas c'est pas le bon
alors là donc elle attendait que j'y
arrive pas ce que c'est je rappelle le
principe de l'émission 7 mois de
relation virtuelle et ensuite il se rend
compte qu allah tanguy parce que ça
faisait sept mois qui parlaient ensemble
c'était vraiment important pour vous
étiez amoureuse de lui ben oui même à
travers une relation virtuelle c'était
bien sûr vous l'aviez combien de fois
par jour à une à deux fois par jour mais
généralement une fois par jour et vous
pariez toute la journée avec lui aussi
aura toute la journée quand même parce
qu'on a des choses à faire l'un est l'os
était comme vote mais qui n'est bah
ouais compagnie
bah oui et donc
sandra est étonné de ne pas voir guy
mais le pire c'est la raison pour
laquelle il n'a pas voulu se déplacer
regardez et après et on se mettra à la
place de son bras parce que c'est ces
couples et
j'aimerais te présenter mes excuses de
ne pas
avoir honoré le rendez vous
j'espère que tu comprendras
je t'embrasse tableau
[Musique]
en fait
administrativement parlant
et qu'il est marié avec une femme et
puis quatre coups
c'est une bataille est là on fait des
trucs ça fait plus d'un an un peu plus
d'un an qu'ils sont plus ensemble ils
sont séparés chacun vit chez lui chacun
a refait sa vie
mais quand on est où là ils se déplacent
même pas pour me le dire lui-même il
envoie son aide
alors oui donc c'est l'ami de
guy roux glissent miles qui est venu
j'adore parce que administrés
il est pris alors c'est vrai que son
bras là vous êtes senti comme en ce
moment là là c'est tout s'effondre comme
une merde en fait ouais vraiment pour le
coup c'était chaud vous y attendiez pas
du tout non ben non moi je on s'est
parlé la veille au caire on voit demain
tout ça nous tiennent bas mais j'arrive
enfin voilà quoi alors le crush 200
draghi était donc mariés depuis quatre
ans guy n'a pas eu le courage d'annoncer
ça directement à son bras il a préféré
donc envoyé ce mail son meilleur ami qui
était en galère totale il faut dire que
cela n'a pas été hyper accueillons aussi
avec lui et c'est normal à la peau
sandra est quelqu'un de réaliste on est
pris plein la tronche et à rien non mais
moi j'aimerais que tu puisses tu prends
ça avec philosophie
tu sors d'où tous tous bien tu sors d'où
et là tu te ramène sur tes grands airs
ait ambonnay tout je me dis que dis tu
veux je fasse quoi wen un g5 vraiment
chauffage suisse en fait tu vois j'ai le
ca tue sans n'est pas même pas le
courage de déplacés devant quelqu'un
ouais sandra les mots qu là mais toi tu
ne connais même pas j'ai même pas
commencé t'inquiète parc est en
[Musique]
toi
et tous parce qu'ils y est
[Applaudissements]
ça va immense désillusion pour vous un
immense désillusion bah ouais un peu
beaucoup vous y attendiez pas du tout
vous disiez c'est pas possible
maintenant je viens à une émission je
m'attends à voir la personne que je suis
censé voir sur vous c'est un moment
hyper important pour vous oui ouais
c'était l'aboutissement de ces sept mois
oui vous dites quand même il est trop
beau pour être prêt de ça il ya
forcément un truc comme
suspect ouais je lui disais fin moi
quand il me demandait ce que je parle
avec d'autres gens oui oui quand même
c'est normal non il n'y a rien de plus
poussé que ça mais toi aussi dix mois
s'il ya un trou ya forcément tout le
monde il ya forcément quelqu'un à qui tu
parles une petite fille comment ça si
vous l'avez dit si vous l'avez dit vous
auriez peut-être compris non normal
genre c'est normal il ya des choses que
je peux cautionner toléré oui normal il
vous aurait dit je suis mariée mais ont
cependant aller doucement comme
rim et donc non j'aurais pas développer
les sentiments
citoyens moi il ya un truc là par
exemple alors jeté en bas
c'est un exemple tu me dis que écoute là
il ya une petite derrière format famous
que tu veux maintenant à toi de voir si
tu veux poursuivre ou si tu veut stopper
s'il ya quelqu'un derrière c'est pas sa
femme
[Rires]
mathieu nault mais en fait ce que veut
dire mathieu je comprends oui et si vous
avez dit je suis plus vraiment avec ma
femme comme il a dit anis et davantage
encore avec elle mais pas que tu peux
avec elle voilà est-ce que a pas laissé
de chance là quoique marié et puis plus
heureux en mariage et s'il avait dit
voilà je suis mariée mais je m'intéresse
à toi vous venez de le dire vous auriez
dit non on continue pas par exemple
c'est possible oui bah voilà donc il a
peut-être bien fait de mentir banon
et sinon vous n'auriez pas parlé non moi
je vois pas les choses comme ça donc
maintenant j'aurais dû moins stopper mes
sentiments j'aurais ralenti le truc
ouais et alors quand même tient quelques
minutes plus tard yaghi donc le mec qui
vous êtes une relation depuis sept mois
qui décident 12 a fait une semaine n'a
évidemment pas été le seul à approach
elle regarde
parle vite
comme j'ai vu quoi me fais pas péter un
câble à travers le téléphone et parle
vite va à l'essentiel et au moins le
courage d'ouvrir ta bouche pour dire
quelque chose de plausible va à
l'essentiel ton ami est venu me dire
quoi que je t'explique c'est ce que je
t'explique est écrit un depuis pas droit
au but ont très vite parce que je me
connais un je me connais très bien
en fait finalement gaieté butin petits
filous et non pas les yaourts d'un grand
il était bien présent au château sur le
lieu de tournage attendait son heure en
extérieur pour avoir une discussion avec
vous sauf que sandra était remonté
forcément vous étiez pas très chaude
pour parler regardez jeudi on ferait ce
qui se passait réellement tu vois c'est
par rapport à certaines choses
je te la durée si si tu acceptes le
parti à l'autre - de schwarzy coupe et
on est sans cesse voir tu envoies ton
ami avec une lettre mal écrite veut et
m'expliquant que tu es marié depuis
quatre ans qu'est-ce que je l'avais dit
au sujet du mensonge si la phrase est
long tu me le dis je vais la raccourcir
non mais le mensonge on en a parlé
répond
sinon ça va je te plaît physiquement
c'est bon ça plaît me regarde moi partir
alors sandra il ya beaucoup de gens
jeudi ils ont accusé d'être une
comédienne et ça monte encore sur les
réseaux sociaux parce que vous pouvez
leur dire ce soir n'être pas du tout une
copine mais ça veut dire quoi comédienne
à ce que je sache personne m'ont
embauché pour être comédienne j'ai pas
eu de vrais sentiments pour guy non mes
histoires oui oui oui mais c'est quoi
parce que vous faites quoi dans la vie
je suis dans je suis manager des projets
voilà en tous genres le coin se rappelle
très clair tout ça a toujours vécu en
prêt quand même on était dans sa presque
toujours sandra sans la chute parce que
qu'est ce que vous dites aux gens qui
disent que vous êtes une comédienne et
que tout ça c'est du fake mais s'ils
disent que je suis une comédienne
j'accepte si pour eux après on peut me
repérer 1,6 à jean dujardin thomas
n'gijol tout ça y est je
sais pas il n'y a pas de souci
maintenant moi je vais dans une émission
telle que celle ci je sais très bien qu
elle va passer devant la france entière
le monde ils devront moi je dois aller
me ridiculiser voilà donc vous si vous
étiez vraiment vous aviez des sentiments
pour guy oui je sais il ya ma mère qui
regarde tous et risque donc non quand
même alors m'en fous
on se pense que c'est cuit à ce moment
là entre guillet vous et pourtant à la
fin de l'émission on apprend que tout ne
s'est pas aussi mal fini que ça regarde
depuis leur dispute au château et
contrairement à ce que vous pourriez
penser
sandra et guy se sont revus
guy s'apprête à divorcer et il a rassuré
sandra sur ses sentiments
ça se passe bien face à ce gars est la
lecture vite que la musique mais je
calme le jeu
alors j'en ai tous aujourd'hui avec des
on en est là
où ça on est là ou là là bas je ne suis
pas gay
attention vous pas ensemble c'est un
bien grand - c'est pour ça que je
préfère dire qu'on est là vous
attendiez-vous à ton voisin oui oui
et vous le croyez locaux questions et
d'y et le reste ça veut dire quoi le
reste pas là pour faire peur des mots
moi j'ai d'abord un même couché non non
non c'était prévu si tout s'était bien
passé on était censé passer le week-end
dans ça il m'a dit qu on va aller faire
un week-end après cette vue macha match
auquel j'étais contente mais vous voyez
comme je vous dis qui va divorcer que
c'est finalement marié je suis pas connu
mais il s est ce qu'on a nommé par
rapport à la question je laisse ce qu'on
appelle le bénéfice du doute un jeune
après bon ça raison elle est plausible
je pense que à sa place tout le monde
aurait menti
vin se pardonner comment impression vous
l'avais un peu pardonner pardonner je
sais pas mais je n'aime pas rester trop
bloqué sur les choses la vie n est pas l
est pas très long je sais pas quand
est-ce qu'elle va s'arrêter dans la
nouvelle pub voilà un jeu les hommes
changent veux pas me passer un grand
mois deuxième chance mais on est là
c'est ce que je dis depuis on est là
vous l'aimez vous avez des sentiments
pour lui bien sûr qu'elle est amoureuse
c'est un grand mot un grand bois ou
amoureuse ouais vous êtes en love je
suis là ouais
j'en voulais à la production pour après
avoir avoir fait ce feu bah quoi d'abord
non mais ça c'est lui qui a décidé et
séguy
quoi que ce soit là bas bon oui oui vous
avez en plus de nous ridiculiser à un
moment est-ce que vous ayez remonte vite
là je vous ai dit voilà je pars parce
que c'est trop peut-être millions pour
moi de vivre cette situation et vous
attendiez peut-être pas à ça vous quand
vous et participez à l'émission bah
c'est clair que non je m'attendais pas à
ça mais maintenant quand j'ai dit que je
pars ou je sais pas quoi penser je suis
au feeling genre là si si ça se passe
mal genre tu veux lâchez tout genre mais
j'y vais au quart de tour et voilà si je
peux partir aussi hein y'a pas de chez
moi quoi je suis pas quelqu'un dit je
m'en vante pas aujourd'hui vous êtes
ensemble ou pas ce qu'on peut considérer
que vous êtes en couple aujourd'hui même
si vous n'avez pas fait quatre heures
après quoi la noix mais faut-il ici il
fait comme j'ai dit là il parle pas
je vous avais kent
non non voilà donc vous êtes con ella
kpatindé trône et ouais c'est toi là tu
te permets
donc c'est un homme bon voilà quoi on
est là quoi on est là on est là où
on est là comme ça mais on est là on est
posé on est là on est quoi j'habite en
somme vous avez tant de noms et
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais t'es toujours amoureux des
sentiments je peux pas dire non même
après tout ça tu n'as quoi je suis
dedans en fait c'est vous et vous avez
tourné dans celui ci on ne prenait pas
et je me suis effondrée ça vous dirait
de devenir autour de la table un jour ou
un
autre vous voyez une très bonne
chronicles olala connaître la charte
niveau des news
ça vous dirait ou pas bah oui car le
tente on le tente on attend le contraire
ont le temps de demain
pichot à l'aide aux malades
[Applaudissements]